[Music]
what about some rapid fire if i sent you
best business advice you've heard does
anything stand out what's your
philosophy on hiring what are you
fascinated by in consumer behavior
you've never had a rocket ship before
right
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vayner nation what is up i am uh gary
vaynerchuk but you know that
and i'm humbled by your subscription to
the podcast
and before we get into my guest and this
new concept these kind of 15-minute
podcast splits to just talk to
entrepreneurs and
get some different perspectives which is
exactly what today's episode's about i
met dave
through one of the key executives at um
at vaynerx vaynermedia nick moritas and
his homies and friends and partners with
dave and i've really enjoyed my
interactions with him and
we were talking about something else the
other day i said hey i've been
playing around with this concept called
like podcast blitz
quick little shots we do these 15 minute
sessions internally at vaynermedia at
vaynerx at 1 37 pm every day
where we do little shots of break up the
day with all the zoom culture and i
interview people and other times other
people do things and
i said why don't i do that for my
community so today's the first episode
of a
of a podcast blitz little 15 minute
interviews
mainly with interesting people things
that are up people are up to something
before i get into that i want to give a
huge shout out to everybody supporting v
friends
i'm just completely and utterly blown
away by the support
uh and i will not let you down i will
spend the next 40 years developing
this intellectual property speaking
about
40 years and building dave why don't you
tell the vayner nation
who you are what company you're running
and then maybe a little bit of an origin
story episode one
you know comic book number one of like
what kind of kid you were and like
all the things that brought you to this
moment and then we'll just i'll do some
rapid fire entrepreneurial questions
i just think you're you're building an
interesting business so i thought it'd
be interesting to people but
i want you to give a little three minute
bio sure
uh david metz ceo and co-founder of
prizeout
uh born on long island born to
entrepreneurial parents
uh then irrigation company uh sprinklers
uh worked for them many a summer
um played lacrosse in high school got a
scholarship to
college was a history major had no idea
what i wanted to do
traded on wall street for a little bit
uh started a company called
slugpo which was online classifieds
um i had a little bit of success there
and then i kind of caught the
entrepreneurial bug
from there i started a board game called
gaggle which was a trivia board game
which did fairly well and
kind of physical yeah it was a physical
game
i um i started in my apartment i uh
i made a a a game out of cardboard and
wrote questions on pieces of paper
and i would put craigslist ads out
test my board game for uh brownies and
beer
and i get these random people that would
show up at my apartment
play the game for 20 minutes tell me
it's too long too short what i could do
better
did that about 15 20 times until i came
to uh what i thought was it was a
perfect uh product and then launched it
and uh you know did the grind went to
christmas fairs and you know pitched the
game to people walking by
and then eventually brought it to online
um
sold a bunch of copies kind of checked
it off my bucket list
um and then from there i started
a trivia app called fleetwit
it was a game where you could bet
friends money that you knew more
than them in sports game of thrones
french literature you name it
um and you would bet your friend 10
bucks and i needed a way for people to
withdraw
money and paypal takes a really long
time to integrate
so i started to offer gift cards as a
way for people to withdraw
money and they seem to like it and then
i raised a little bit of money and then
i started to do paid acquisition
and then over time it really started to
bother me that
i'm spending all this money on facebook
ads but every time song withdrew to a
gift card
they'd be essentially withdrawing to a
brand dominoes uh
amazon whatever and those brands are
essentially acquiring users
the same thing i was paying facebook for
so then i would reach out to some of the
brands like papa john's and i say hey
would you pay me to feature your gift
card as a withdrawal option
and they were like heck yeah and from
there that's where i got prize out and
then i launched it and it's kind of been
been a rocket ship ever since
uh vayner vayner nation friends this is
why i have devon here
dave is one of us i'm one of you we're
all one of the same which is
i think people miss moments and what you
did dave well
in the story you just told is what i'm
trying to push people
towards doing more of which is sometimes
we get into our cocoon into our hamster
wheel i was just on with
nick our fellow buddy in a meeting with
a bunch of other leaders and i'm like
you guys are living in your ecosystem
take a step out look and it'll help you
you
scratched your own itch you listened to
the market
you created a business out of the
subtleties of tasting it within a
business
in a weird way when you i i didn't know
about the board game the physical
in a weird way that was your progression
from that board game
in a weird way prize out is still linked
to the board game because the board game
created a game
in mobile and you kind of just kept
building until prize out happened
that's fascinating i actually never i've
never thought of it that way but you're
right
one thing led to another yeah i was
listening i was like oh you went
physical board game
it was during that era where mobile
gaming was happening you're like this is
stupid i'm doing the physical [ __ ] i can
go mobile
you want mobile you iterated and then
the feature within the feature became
the actual business
literally that [ __ ] board game you
know it was funny the way you told the
story you're like i scratched that itch
it actually became the proxy to the to
what you're doing
in a weird way similar for me like
especially with v
friends right now my crazy nft project
it's just a culmination of many things
and i think a lot of people
going through their career right now the
wins the losses the
grinds they don't realize those are all
ingredients
that they've added to the repertoire and
if they can cook
this is the important analogy if they
can cook the meal with those ingredients
they go like
you you not only came up with that
hypothesis
you've executed to this rocket ship
what is the biggest thing you've never
had a rocket ship before right am i
correct no
i've i've sat on the other side of the
table begging
for money and now i'm on the other side
of the table where
our rounds are massively oversubscribed
there's not a
week that doesn't go by that some
private equity or vc
company uh tries to throw money in the
last 45 days we've had
six acquisition inquiries i would never
appreciate this unless i went through
kind of getting pooped on all those
right you thought it was normal you
would think it was normal
i thought you know raising money or
getting getting interest was the hardest
thing in the world to do and now being
on the other side of the table it's
what about what about for the operators
in here what is the
biggest thing you've learned navigating
a rocket let's use a different analogy
navigating a 300 mile an hour sports car
versus uh you know so you know this is
the best part i've had them too
some of those lemons you bought off the
lot like what's the what's the biggest
thing you've learned with context of
the difference between a rocket ship and
maybe let's say a tortoise of a business
that's just plotting along
i i think that i could never be able to
steer a rocket ship
unless i learned how to steer the
tortoise or the taurus
first right like i needed to like i
needed to get my bachelor's right
before i got my masters before i got my
phd right
you would not respect money unless you
bootstrapped unless you've
you know you've used your own money and
and you've you've had to worry about
paying payroll and gone through all that
tough stuff to be in this position now
and appreciate and be able to handle it
so if i was 22 years old and people were
throwing money at me
i would have no idea how to handle it
unless i went through what i went
through in the past
who who's given you the best um give me
give me a great piece of advice
from a family member a friend if i said
to you best
business advice you've heard or or and
it you know
and what was best for you right it was
best for you
does anything stand out wow
you know it usually you know it's hard
for me just to
come up with it it usually comes in
situational um
you know my parents ever since i was a
little kid would always ingrain
because i was you know you're cl your
classic hdhd hyper kid
right i would i would say whatever is on
my mind and my parents
constantly ingrained you know think
before you talk think before you talk
and it sounds so simple and i didn't
realize it at the
at the time when i was a kid but now as
an adult um
it's actually had a profound impact on
me
i love that what um
what's something that you're
affected by as a consumer dave in this
little blitz of a
actually by the way i'm getting
bombarded by my audience for jobs
when you're on a rocket ship you're
always hiring where can people find you
and maybe find the company to do a
little homework find you and maybe reach
out for jobs
let me just share it quick uh you can
for jobs you can hit us up on linkedin
just just search prizeout um to find
more information
right prize yep oh you tries p-r-i-z-e
o-u-t prize out
you can get for jobs linkedin and for
more information
go to our website priceout.com love it
um what about you as the consumer i
always think the people
that have the reps are real
entrepreneurs
executed wins losses and everything in
between
i always love their i always want to ask
on this show
this blitz podcast these 15 minutes i
want to ask them
what uh what's from their standpoint
what's um what's catching their
attention
what's catching your attention wow um
since my life products yeah i know
you're 24 7. but
anything hitting it's a good question
um it's the standard stuff you know
slack is
is the future you know uh it defines my
life i'm on slack way more than i'm on
instagram or tip talk or twitter or
anything like that
i i i use slack more than i text more
than i use the phone that that
that is my life right now and i know now
that's all on the application portal
yeah it's it has a greater holding me
than
than social media ever did like if i
don't pick up my phone and i don't know
because because that's that's because
it's your utility right
yep yeah yeah that you know it's funny
i i but it's got a social element to it
right
oh for sure kind of like the reddit
meets email
ecosystem that it has yeah if i don't
if there's not something going on at
work then i feel like we're not
progressing
um and i feel like i should be doing
more right i need
i need to be solving problems every day
and if there's not a problem to solve
on slack exactly so what do we need to
do
what about some rapid fire what's your
philosophy on hiring
no there's two things we don't tolerate
drama and entitlement
those are two things we we i can't deal
with um we do
we are moving too fast to have people
come in and
be cancerous we are very much a
meritocracy
um i think new york is the best place in
the world to hire because
you have all these people that are
brilliant but are in jobs where they're
using
five percent of their potential and they
don't care about money they want to be
a part of something something bigger
than them um
so what we offer is that so i think we
have the ability to be
super selective and we we try to you
know as cliche as it sounds and steve
jobs said you know
hire slowly and and fire quickly
what about um what about
things you admire in leaders that you'd
like to be better at
a little self-awareness a little
humility
what what do you admire in other leaders
that you've heard of
or you've seen that you'd like to work
on since you're still a youngster and
have many more years of this
yeah it's a good question i think it's
changed over the years i think it used
to be
things that i'm never going to be good
at like my adhd
i'll never be good at details i wish
that i wish i could go i suck i wish
i don't i just want to surround myself
with epic details people who i love and
trust
and that that in the last two years has
changed my life i've read this mit
study where it was like stop trying to
be what you're not and surround yourself
with people that complement your
weaknesses
and that has changed my life so i love
that greatest strength one of the best
drinks i have
in business no question uh
what about um what i'm really curious
about
is what are you fascinated about
in consumer behavior like for example
i'll give you one for me and then you
could give you another second to think
i'm fascinated by what people think is a
waste of money
and what they don't think is a waste of
money so like the same person
can be like super pissed about like you
know
uh buying a coffee for three bucks and
they're like that's crazy it's gotta be
25 cents
but we'll buy a four thousand dollar
handbag and
and and think that's like completely
normal you know you know i'm fascinated
by consumer psychology
or what they do or they don't like you
know like
the reason i'm really asking you is
you're getting to see a lot of data like
what they
how they do it what they choose is that
i'm curious if anything stands out
yeah so we so we're a withdrawal option
for various industries insurance payroll
gaming gig economy lottery you name it
anywhere where someone's earned or won
money um so let's say somebody from
gaming right you're on paddy power
draftkings right you win a hundred
dollars right
when you withdraw that money through
prize out you're obviously selecting a
gift card
but that behavior is very much more like
i just won money i want to treat myself
right so they're looking at much more
luxury items if you're a gig worker
right you work for doordash or something
right or
a waiter and you're using prize out to
withdraw your earnings it's much more
utility like i need
gasoline grocery uh it's christmas time
gifts for my kids right so depending on
the vertical that they're coming from uh
dictates their their purchasing power
which has been really fascinating to see
and what's even more fascinating is when
someone buys a gift card through
prizeout
uh 50 over 50 50 of users
spend it within the first four hours so
we hate the word gift card because
they're not buying it for anyone
but themselves so once they buy it they
actually use it which has been pretty
pretty fascinating as quickly as they do
dave wrapping up the rapid fire podcast
i'm excited about this
format what up parting insights
for all the entrepreneurs or operators
employees investors
what's uh what's a little mets uh wisdom
here on the part out
yeah i think it's i think gary you
actually kind of put in my
mind like who would ever thought that
you went from
a board game to disrupting fintech like
that that's a story and i never i didn't
realize until we started talking
i'm here for that i appreciate it
dave thanks for being on the show
everybody please uh hit me up on social
let me know i want to do a little
these blitzy introduce you to some
people i have the luxury of
knowing a lot of people some under the
radar superstars like our man bets here
and
i want to do more of this kind of stuff
let me know if you like this format the
fast you saw the rapid style i kind of
went with
um let me know what you think and uh if
we like it we'll keep doing more of
these
dave once again prize out congrats we'll
talk soon
thanks jerry youtube bachelor what's up
it's garyvee first of all thank you so
much i hope you're doing super well
during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because
my commitment and exploration of youtube
is about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon